[Music]
and no experience required me yup Oh
submitted by P cool wash that'd be cool
a nuclear power station received
backlash after attempting to use a
bikini contest to hire interests in
China
it's gotta be something else because
Chinese people aren't horny they're just
Shady
weren't they using that as a marketing
tactic when they open up a store
something they had a bunch of like Asian
girls but it wasn't typical Chinese
behavior typical Chinese behaviors like
let me cheat
that's Vietnamese behavior let me beat
my employees you know means nummies
because we want to put girls in bikinis
on everything you know that Vietnamese
lady that has the airplane bikini
airline she's the first Vietnamese
billionaire mhm
and it's a woman yeah something about
interns in bikinis yeah okay so
conversation was good the nuclear plants
in the Czech Republic you're close yeah
that they posted up on their Facebook
ten images of these ten high school
graduates graduates okay yeah graduated
bikini suppose I'm a boater very telling
their Facebook followers to like their
favorite girl in order for her to get an
opportunity to have an internship at the
nuclear plant
I like this qualification process me too
I look too young
this is this is very progressive I can
tell that safety is very important to
these people because she has a safety
hat on yeah hmm they look very
uncomfortable and the setting isn't
right they're there in the nuclear oh
whoa I don't like a green screen no
they're in the radioactive the
radioactive girls you think you're hot
I'm radioactive they all have the same
body type I like different hair yeah
yeah what kind of fear actually yeah I
didn't know Czech girls were so fit I
trying to work around that man that's
too distracting them just hire all of
them they were saying like how are you
gonna qualify an intern just based off
of their look of course that's all you
need hahaha
I've been looking for quality here like
a personally I don't I don't I can't do
that yeah but then I can okay I'll get
fired the next day because I didn't get
anything done literally I'll get fired
I'm not trying to [ __ ] them in their
bikinis it's not that but it's like I've
already seen that so now my visual all I
see is that now you don't mean all you
see is us in bikinis do you guys like
yeah but anyways like the funny thing is
it's all females for the intern there's
no guys there's no who have one guy
entered and [ __ ] beautiful because
you guys you can specialize women that
you don't have a relationship with you
know they mean so like if you look at
people on TV that's why if there's like
celebrity crushes I have right I never
want to meet them in person cuz it'll
ruin it'll ruin it they need to be a
mystery to me you'll notice a [ __ ]
hairy mole you [ __ ] it up you [ __ ]
like like a female celebrity I really
like right and then I talked to them
we have great conversation you know it
was like [ __ ] I like you now like I like
you as a person the more you spend time
with the woman the uglier they become
yeah well that ugly the less of a sex
object yeah it's like you're like a
plant to mean right now what the [ __ ]
man you're starting to join their
presence you like hearing them speak and
[ __ ] you want to respect them yeah you
respect them know their tits have no no
body value at all you look at it and
it's like that's like my mom's titties
they just exist you look at your mom
cities and things no I don't [ __ ]
look at it like I'm gonna suck all my
mom's titties like it was [ __ ] 1983
and [ __ ] what's the significance of that
year either bored during that time well
I just say it's a baby you know like
like yeah the significant
I must suck on that titty like I was a
baby anyways the nuclear plant ended up
saying like well this was just a
different approach and how we were
showing insurance cuz they claim that
they have about 900 internships every
single year so we gotta find a better
way to weed them out I see it was just a
[ __ ] perv did you bring this to the
states result if it was me and someone
told me hey do you want to join a
contest and you know it's a swimsuit
contest am i cool what surprise you get
an unpaid internship at a [ __ ]
ugliest nuclear nuclear plant like why
the [ __ ] would I don't you want to be
like Homer Simpson they were saying that
whatever career the girl is trying to
head towards like if she's wanting to go
into marketing that she could work in
the media department of the nuclear
plant you know you know what I like
about this though there the Czech
Republic is way more [ __ ]
straightforward than the u.s. OR bunch
of because we we try to hide the fact
that like women are beautiful and then
like we want to work around beautiful
people but then they're they're just
straight up which ones the hottest
because that one's gonna be cool a lot
of people angry in the Czech Republic
yeah well they're [ __ ] sore losers
because they're probably not waning the
voting thing is lame though I've seen
there's a contest out there don't know
what's cold but it's like you get to be
on the cover of some internet magazine
since I'm in a real magazine what if
this was like one out of 20 challenges
like what if they had to do other skill
related things like juggling but this is
just one like you have beauty pageant
now yeah so it's like you have to win
the beauty portion of it too so it's
like maybe that's not all they're going
for is just one but then they also have
to hula-hoop really nice they also have
to like do math really well and it's
kind of like stuff like that yeah it's a
little odd because they're saying that
the purpose of this competition was to
promote technical education I see that
me too
how fabrics in the bikini yep modern
fabric a hardhat safety first
yep I don't know I think it's a great
idea and they need to bring it here dude
I don't want a sexy ass people to work
with though men why cuz you get horny
yeah how do you do it with us then well
who me wouldn't mean with us difficult
no how do you focus oh no wonder you're
late over there what do you mean I don't
get
I mean you're attractive okay get the
[ __ ] out here also attractive [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] tainted all right goddamn
no she [ __ ] rude gal gadot for me
[ __ ] last week to hell I took all her
poses that I'm not the one she looks
like oh I'm not saying it but for my
experience in working those places where
they hire pretty girls it gets [ __ ]
crazy in there man I worked in a bar
like a Vietnamese bar once what's up
ladies bar like it [ __ ] a lot of New
Wave music basically huh and smoking
inside mm-hmm Stevie B within like the
first two months there there was a rumor
because I was friends at the girl nerd
there like all the girls are saying
you're an escort like I drove a 98
accord that's a pour water into every
time I Drive somewhere I'm [ __ ]
terrible I would I would be so happy if
somebody said that if as I heard really
that's a compliment
those girls turned out to be an escort
because they were bein a dude a rich
dude that came in all the time but he
had security cameras all over his house
and he would blackmail them oh yeah dude
free set yeah smart idea for advice from
you know one grant should investigate a
message me she's like can you teach me
how to get out of this I'm like I was
never ends I don't even ought to get you
[ __ ] out of there if you want to be an
escort you have to be ready to let your
parents know yeah cuz if someone's like
hey you got to keep sucking my dick or
else I'm gonna tell your mom but
somebody has ports they don't have to
have sex though right sometimes just
companionship yeah all right just don't
suck dick just just go to the beach and
hang out and talk about life is [ __ ] a
sauna I have a friend on Facebook she's
a really good friend why she was go-go
dancer before and now she's an escort
she's very open about it her stories are
[ __ ] crazy on her Facebook it's
awesome fun dude I love reading that
world because it's like oh my god the
things that you ladies had to do it's
like crazy yeah
he sound like such a gossip drunk
because you know why it's like it's like
I can't even imagine myself sucking that
much dick in a one night like down dude
how much is that much like 10 more than
one it's crazy enough for me cuz every
time I look at that I'm like oh my god I
came a last face make a lot of money too
you would know maybe Gail I know I know
a couple of Korean little little little
Thome boys and they make a lot more foot
old lady I can't call me boys they
called Thome boys only me
so Tommy is just like it's an escort oh
I would make the worst as you would
because I would just do it for free
I mean like literally you could you
could tell who the Tommy girls are in
k-town really they may make a decent
amount of money like you see them making
a lot of money and they're not really it
depends on what they want to do but I
know like these dudes like the two guys
and I know they told me that they don't
do anything really
they just hang out with the ladies they
karaoke with them they pour like drinks
down their throat and [ __ ] I mean I hug
them to give my kisses on the cheek and
they walk away that weekend with my
regrets these women are so physically
deprived all they need is this and
they're like well what they told me was
that like their husbands cheat on them
with like like Tomi girls so they take
their husbands money and they do it back
to them so inside well if you're gonna
do it you give me money away I'm taking
your money and I'm gonna do it back
right back to you so they're just having
fun doing their own thing like healthy
relationship like like even in Korea I'm
not sure about Japan I'm pretty sure
like in Japan too like in Korea and
Japan there's like a unsaid thing where
businessmen do they go out and they
cheat on their wives
this is our common in Asia yeah like
it's like they're mean it's a part of
the culture because long time ago they
found love outside of the household love
was a separate thing from husband and
wife was it because it was arranged
probably I think so cuz everything was
arranged up until recently like a seems
like a pretty cool system so the white
was all is just it's just the business
transactions just to build a family with
the person you don't have to love them I
made a bad business transaction that's
okay you know what though I feel like
the reason why there are so many
divorced so much drama so much [ __ ]
is because how much we expect from our
partners now we expect them to be
perfect we want them to be beautiful we
want them to
of us we want them to be nice but not
only that they have to like also be good
in their careers and all these things
and it's like how about just someone
that's healthy that could pop out a baby
and who's really nice to you and who
could take care [ __ ] guys are nice you
guys want like a [ __ ] hot a
supermodel that's also super talented
like a PhD years and then yeah and in
super intelligent and at the same time
like cooks Lauren star looks like a porn
star really great so an unrealistic it's
very unrealistic same with females into
that I just don't want to grow the I
just don't want that that's all I want
yeah I just want a lady who is you
should want any worship and then other
than that she could make me laugh and
then I'm pretty much good every now and
then PB okay cuz sometimes I beat me too
you know so something pretty bubbly boom
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode if you haven't already make sure
to hit that subscribe button because we
upload videos every single day for you
guys now to watch more videos check them
out up here
[Music]